Which manager signed the same player 3 times
in 3 different clubs?
Hmm. Cool. Okay.
Can we get bonus points if we guess the same player
as well? Not back to back.
Yeah, if you can get.
Yeah. Yes, Dave.
Okay, so not back to back,
not 3. Not back to back.
No, no, not like today.
He left the next day.
Next year you left the next year.
He left and he followed each other.
Cause obviously then contracts in.
It is impossible to do that.
All right. He loved each other, man. He was.
All right, ask me questions.
I think I've. No,
I think I've got a guess.
I think I'm ready. Okay, yeah.
I'll give you guys one guess each.
Let me ask some questions first. Go on, Thai.
All right, I'm, um.
Did they. Did the manager manage in a Premier League? Yes.
This. Is that too much info?
No. You can't give the other leagues? No,
I got three leagues.
No, no. Ask me.
What do you mean?
All right. Premier League? Yes.
La Liga? Yes.
I'm not giving you more. Okay,
but you said different clubs.
It could be two.
Premier. La Liga.
La Liga. Awesome.
I guess. Questions?
Um, not me. Oh,
I mean a player that's paid in a Premier League or.
Yeah, okay. There's not a lot of players.
Ah, I was thinking of. What's the third club, though?
What's the third?
Yeah, cause I was thinking. He's gone. Premier. League.
Then he went to.
Mmm. Tough. What's the first letter?
Same manager and same player.
Tough. Let's get it. Guesses. Come on.